in Andor the planet farex is a hotbed of  activity leading up to Marva andor's  funeral Imperial forces land on the  planet as Rebel agents huddle and the  whole town is a buzzed with preparations  in a shot of a local bar early in  episode 12 a smaller Patron is seen  walking back to a table where the drink  is waiting it's dark in the bar and the  shots only lasts for a couple of seconds  but the alien appears to be the same  species as Mars Kanata a bargoa has the  same stature head shape and even similar  goggles to Mars making this seem like an  intentional Easter egg and or already  has a vaguely similar alien in the  doctor who tries to save nemec in  episode 6 but that character is pretty  clearly a different species the alien  and pharynx on the other hand looks to  be exactly the same kind of creature as  Mars of course since we still don't know  the name or history of that species this  little Cameo remains shrouded in mystery